Minister to move second-leading or Prime
Minister to move secondly there is a new
mood in the UK House of Commons the
knife-edge brexit votes of the autumn
are now ancient history the tension
replaced by political inevitability and
in front of the newly expanded ranks of
conservative MPs Boris Johnson was
enjoying the moment Hills free will
record that the first act of this new
Parliament in its earliest days was to
break the ice floes and find a new way
through a new passage through two
unsuspected oceans of opportunity his
parliamentary majority means that Prime
Minister Boris Johnson can now press
ahead with his vision of brexit the new
law will prohibit any trade talks
extension beyond December of 2020 and it
weakens parliamentary scrutiny of the
executive the clause on protecting
workers rights has been removed and a
previous commitment to receive
unaccompanied child refugees has also
been watered down critics and opponents
say the changes show the Prime Minister
can't be trusted for all the promises
over the past few weeks that they are
the party to protect rights at work at
the very first opportunity they've
removed the basic provisions they said
would be part of this bill that does not
bode well
fresh from an emphatic election victory
the Prime Minister has little need to
contemplate the critics or placate his
opponents but he will have to consider
the voters especially those who switched
from labour and in his words lent the
Conservatives their support in the
election the simple fact though is that
Johnson has the numbers with him the
eyes to the right 358 the nose to the
left
234 the bill his bill will become law in
January Paul Brennan al Jazeera
Westminster